hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm Joan Humphrey we are going to talk
about some batman casting stuff hence my
pandering shirt that's right mine too
Tim Burton oh you made it work uh-huh
because he directed Beetlejuice yeah
definitely which has Michael Keenan who
was the star of burden really Robocop
Rieman Robocop remake Paul Dano has been
cast as the Riddler people we haven't
talked about any of them casting at all
other than Pattinson well I put out a
poll on our community page on YouTube of
should we talk about this paul dano news
or any of the additional casting there
are channels that whenever there's one
bit of casting yeah I do a video about
it but we really have no real context to
go off of here so far even right up to
Paul Dano every casting bit has just
made me go that sounds about right
that's a good comics reprobate I feel
like they can easily do that you know
there hasn't been a casting choice other
than the initial reaction I had up by
myself at El Pollo Loco to Robert
Pattinson being cast but then going wait
a minute he's done a lot of great films
now he can do this I quickly got there
Jeffrey Wright as Commissioner Gordon
just makes a lot of sense to me zoe
kravitz that makes a lot of sense to me
right down to Paul Dano I think it was
yesterday Jonah Hill had left talks to
be in this film I think he was optioning
to play a Riddler this is all movie
Newstalk none of the actors themselves
have come out and smoking about but he's
a paul dano type he left it apparently
Seth Rogen was even being courted at one
point to play penguin you know look at
that that's a choice I would have to do
one as long as much as I like Jonah Hill
and Seth Rogen and you know Jonah Hill
he does got those Oscar nominations i
think paul dano is a better casting fit
Oh for someone like Riddler
just another video all right submitted
like I don't really care for the Jim
Carrey portrayal of Riddler I just
finished season three of Gotham and the
actor who plays Edward nygma there that
right there's my cup of tea and I think
if Riddler is the main villain in this
story I think that's great because Matt
Reeves has gone on record really talking
about how he wants to make this more of
a detective story you know there's a
point where we want a Deathstroke to be
the villain but that'd be like a cool
martial arts
bad move or those two is like an
assassin going up against Batman I'd be
awesome but I think if you wanted to
make a solid detective film yeah make
Riddler your main villain because he's
all about the crime and he's all about
leaving riddles and clues just solve it
yourself in testing Batman's analysis
skills yeah that's the whole Lauria as
you get to watch a showdown of wit this
point if it was just a showdown of bran
it might be a little underwhelming and
yeah with all the build-up that this is
going to be focusing in on the most
detective esque iterations of Batman
like that's what makes me excited and an
actor like paul dano and the chops that
he has and also just the kind of odd
quality that he has to his persona he's
great at like the off-putting dark
disturbed nerdy kind of characters like
socially strange but still he's got this
energy about him that really lends
itself I think to a character awake this
where he could have a lot of fun but
still be very dramatically gripping and
scary and because there's this appealing
yet unsettling quality that he brings
and I think to have him be Riddler is
his perfect choice physical appearance
wise maybe not akin to how they've
apparently been reshaping him in the
comics to be like a lot cooler which I
know some people have been saying there
they're hoping they do that approach
with this Riddler I don't know I mean I
like the more traditional version of a
Riddler II kind of character and I think
paul dano better suits that material but
well then it was an incredible actor and
he's someone I feel like with Jonah Hill
as great of a job is I think he would
actually do and delivering this
performance I wonder how much I'd be
able to actually see past Jonah Hill and
only see Riddler where I feel like would
paul dano that's not really gonna be a
problem no no I feel like he's the type
of actor who can definitely immerse into
that to the point where you might still
be aware that sim but you're not
thinking about it in the same way the
prospect of Jonah Hill is a Riddler is
kind of distracting to me although if
you wanted to be penguin I can see that
happen I don't think I just think he
could bring that character's qualities a
different way weirdly as much as all
these casting choices have not even read
down to Pattinson have not been like the
most obvious choice like Jonah Hill
Josh GAD would be like the most obvious
of choices for penguin these choices
have been in the right market that's not
too arty it's not like whoa this is way
out of the realm over yeah and it's not
exactly the most obvious either it's
right in the middle where's like that's
a perfect fit for something that is not
completely predictable yeah yeah Jessica
Chastain is Beverly yeah you know like
Paul Paul Dano is I feel like he is the
most interesting mark here because zoe
kravitz it feels like she's just in the
exact right point in time to get cast as
Catwoman it seems to make a lot of sense
yeah and then jeffrey wright is at a
point in his career to where he has a
lot more clout and he is taking a bit
more of these elder statesman roles and
I feel like having something to chew on
like a Jim Gordon where he actually gets
to be at odds with the main plot and
everything I feel like that would be a
great use of his chops yeah this feels
like it's being cast like a film yeah
that's just fun to me which is exciting
to me I suppose
if any one of them is the most
surprising to me is it's been jeffrey
wright well we're all speculating about
who's in a play Jim Gordon none of us
really speculate about it being a person
of color specifically the Mexican Latino
actor Jeff we just want to speculate
about it but then when you hear Jeffrey
right it's like that doesn't even matter
at behavior no it's not it has nothing
to do with that because you know you see
the amount of work I've seen this guy do
my introduction to this guy is actually
in the HBO miniseries Angels in America
where he played multiple roles
two very different roles he's incredible
in it and then it seems like as he's
done more work over time he's often in
some type of a political role to a
certain degree or some kind of highly
intellectual but maybe not that most in
power type of role you think exactly
world things but then you think Jim
Gordon ER or lieutenant detective
whichever stage Gore's never had this in
this point in his life really yeah of
Jeffrey Wright easily with the kind of
delivery his look the glass I just
needed to see it and I'm excited to see
him play a guy I hope to play a guy with
a lot of authority and who is gonna have
that kind of thing yes you know because
I feel like that is a shade that I'm not
as used to seeing him get to sink his
teeth into you know and with zoe kravitz
his Catwoman one of the comics I grew up
the most reading
love the adaptation the DC animated
movie of Batman year one that was the
first thing I saw where Selina Kyle was
a black woman casting that person of
color for Catwoman is not a surprise
it's kind of just bit engrained in my
head even though it's small and Batman
year one it's one of my favorite
portrayal of her I'm hoping they kind of
do something along the lines of that
specific take I don't know if she's
gonna be full-on Catwoman here because
based off this amount of casting she
might just be Selina Kyle in this movie
and not Catwoman per se be curious yeah
I mean that's the other thing about this
film too is I'm sort of expecting maybe
at least a couple slight variations or
subversions on what we're coming to
expect yeah what we're coming to expect
them to do in the first movie if this is
gonna this seems like it has more
potential for franchise than say Joker
which is probably gonna get expanded on
the reason why I'm kind of curious to
see if zoe kravitz is character will
just be Selina Kyle in this film and not
Catwoman is because there's a lot of
characters here the rumor has it that
this is taking a lot of inspiration from
the Batman comic the long Halloween
which is fantastic comic still it's like
even though there's pretty decent amount
of row gallery characters in the long
Halloween when you're relaunching your
Bat verse movie I'm still like yeah yeah
even in the hands of Matt Reeves and
everything I still do have a little bit
of that in anyone's hands I'm always
like please take your time a little bit
and don't go too overboard introducing
or setting up things so you can not add
stuff if you have to but I do want zoe
kravitz to really stand out so many
things I rarely remember what she does
in those movies because she's always
she's always has this like underserved
character she's always good I never
complain about zoe kravitz as an actress
but her characters I tend to kind of
forget about and maybe that's it cuz I I
go back and forth on her too because it
like on the surface I think she's a fine
actress she's got chops and there's
something about most of her performances
I haven't been able to connect with
personally and I don't know if that is
just in the writing like you look at
something like fantastic beasts to which
just completely under serves her
character even though it's thrust sore
at you so I'm hoping that yet maybe this
can also be a chance for at least as my
movie going goes for her to really own
that
and to leave a big impression on me yeah
it's like I always remember she's in it
just can't really tell you like the the
defining traits of this character but
Hollywood loves her the role I remember
her Mohsen actually his big little lies
I've only seen season one of that when
it first came out and she is great in
that show too and a combination of
everything I've seen from her all around
big little lies she and someone who's a
little bit more like sensual presence
and big little lies and no tougher
characters like the divergent series or
x-men first class hell yeah you know
things like that so yeah I feel like all
the casting for this has been great it's
it's a good fine line of not the most
conventional picks just right there who
are you just popular you would offend
you would entice have enough it's one of
those things where you wouldn't think to
cast them but when you cast them it
makes sense yeah yeah sounds like pretty
long yes I think this is gonna be gonna
be a hell of a film alright guys well
are you excited for Paul to Anna to play
The Riddler what are your hopes for this
Batman movie which casting choice is
gotten you the most excited outside of
Robert Pattinson comment below you guys
can subscribe at the real rejects click
the notification bill catch you guys
soon